en sistemas de caja negra relacionados con la autoridad,
en cosas como contratos legales, regulación y seguros,
y depositamos menos confianza en las demás personas.
La confianza se institucionalizó y se basó en las comisiones.
Se habla mucho de cómo la confianza en las instituciones
y en muchas marcas corporativas
se ha ido reduciendo a un ritmo constante y continúa haciéndolo.
Constantemente me quedo atónita ante importantes abusos de confianza:
el pirateo del teléfono de News Corp,
el escándalo de las emisiones de Volkswagen,
el abuso generalizado en la iglesia católica,
el hecho de que un solo mísero banquero
fuera a la cárcel tras la gran crisis financiera,
o, más recientemente, los papeles de Panamá
que revelaron cómo los ricos pueden explotar
los regímenes fiscales en paraísos fiscales.
Y lo que realmente me sorprende
es por qué a los líderes les resulta tan difícil
disculparse, y quiero decir pedir perdón de corazón,
cuando se rompe nuestra confianza.
Sería fácil concluir que la confianza en las instituciones
no está funcionando porque estamos hartos
de la pura osadía de las élites deshonestas,
pero lo que está pasando ahora
es más profundo que el cuestionamiento exorbitante
del tamaño y estructura de las instituciones.
Estamos comenzando a darnos cuenta
de que la confianza en las instituciones
no fue diseñada para la era digital.
Los convencionalismos de cómo la confianza se construye,
se maneja, se pierde y se repara
-- en marcas, líderes y en sistemas enteros --
se están dando la vuelta.
Ahora bien, esto es emocionante,
pero da miedo, ya que
nos obliga a muchos de nosotros a tener que replantearnos
cómo se construye y destruye la confianza
con nuestros clientes, con nuestros empleados
e incluso a quienes queremos.
El otro día estaba hablando con el director general
de una cadena de hoteles puntera internacionalmente
y, como suele suceder, abordamos el tema de Airbnb.
Me admitió que su éxito lo tenía perplejo.
Estaba perplejo ante cómo una compañía
que depende de la voluntad de los desconocidos
para confiar el uno en el otro
pudiera funcionar tan bien en 191 países.
Así que le dije que tenía que confesarle algo,
y me miró un poco extrañado,
y le dije que
-- estoy segura de que muchos de Uds. también lo hacen --
en el hotel no siempre me molesto en colgar mis toallas
cuando termino,
pero que nunca haría eso como huésped en Airbnb.
Y la razón por la cual nunca lo haría como huésped en Airbnb
es porque los invitados saben que serán calificados por los anfitriones,
y que es probable que esas calificaciones influyan
en su habilidad de negociar en el futuro.
Es un simple ejemplo de cómo la confianza virtual
cambia nuestros comportamientos
en el mundo real,
nos hace más responsables
de maneras que todavía ni podemos imaginar.
No estoy diciendo que no necesitemos hoteles
o formas tradicionales de autoridad.
Pero lo que no podemos negar es que
la forma en que la confianza fluye a través de la sociedad
está cambiando y está creando un gran giro
que se aleja del siglo XX,
definido por la confianza en las instituciones,
y va hacia el siglo XXI,
estimulado por una confianza diseminada.
La confianza ya no es descendente.
Se está disgregando e invirtiendo.
Y no es opaca y lineal.
Está emergiendo una nueva receta de la confianza
que, de nuevo, se distribuye entre las personas
y se basa en la responsabilidad.
Este cambio solo va a acelerarse
con la aparición de la cadena de bloques,
la innovadora tecnología de libro de contabilidad que sustenta a Bitcoin.
Ahora bien, seamos honestos,
tratar de comprender cómo funciona la cadena de bloques
es desconcertante.
Y una de las razones es que implica tener que procesar
algunos conceptos bastante complicados
con nombre terribles.
Me refiero a algoritmos criptográficos y a funciones de control,
a personas llamadas mineros, que verifican las transacciones
-- todo lo que creó esta persona o personas
misteriosas llamadas Satoshi Nakamoto.
Ese es un inmenso salto de confianza que todavía no ha tenido lugar.
(Aplausos)
Pero intentemos imaginar esto.
'The Economist' describió a la cadena de bloques de forma elocuente,
como la gran cadena de estar seguro de las cosas.
El modo más sencillo en que puedo describirlo es,
imaginen los bloques como hojas de cálculo
llenas de activos.
Podría ser un título de propiedad.
Podrían ser acciones.
Podría ser un activo creativo, como los derechos de una canción.
Cada vez que algo se mueve
de un lugar del registro a otro sitio,
esa transferencia de activos genera un registro de tiempo
y queda públicamente registrada en la cadena de bloques.
Es así de simple. Bien.
Así que la verdadera repercusión de la cadena de bloques
es que elimina la necesidad de cualquier tipo de terceros,
como un abogado
o un intermediario de confianza,
o quizá no, un intermediario del gobierno
para facilitar el intercambio.
Si volvemos a la pila de confianza,
aún se tiene que confiar en la idea,
tienes que confiar en la plataforma,
pero ya no tienes que confiar en la otra persona
del modo tradicional.
Las repercusiones son inmensas.
Del mismo modo en que Internet abrió de par en par
las puertas a una era de la información
disponible para todo el mundo,
la cadena de bloques revolucionará la confianza a escala global.
Ahora bien, he esperado hasta el final
para mencionar a Uber a propósito,
porque reconozco que es un ejemplo polémico
y ampliamente sobreutilizado,
pero en el contexto de una nueva era de confianza,
es un gran caso práctico.
Veremos casos de abuso de la confianza diseminada.
Ya lo hemos visto, y puede salir horriblemente mal.
No me sorprende que veamos protestas,
que veamos protestas de las asociaciones de taxis
alrededor del mundo,
tratando de hacer que los gobiernos prohíban Uber
basándose en el argumento de que no es seguro.
Casualmente estaba en Londres
el día en que ocurrieron estas protestas
y casualmente me fijé en un tuit
de Matt Hancock, que es un ministro británico de empresa.
Escribió, "¿Alguien tiene información
sobre esta aplicación #Uber de la que todo el mundo habla?"
(Risas)
"Hasta hoy no había oído hablar de ella".
Ahora bien, las asociaciones de taxistas
legitimaron la primera fase de la pila de confianza.
Legitimaron la idea que estaban tratando de eliminar,
y las suscripciones crecieron un 850 % en 24 horas.
Este es un ejemplo muy sólido
de cómo, una vez que tiene lugar un giro de la confianza
alrededor de un comportamiento o de un sector entero,
ya no se puede invertir la historia.
Cada día, cinco millones de personas darán un salto de confianza
y se moverán con Uber.
En China, en Didi, la plataforma de viajes compartidos,
tienen lugar 11 millones de viajes cada día.
Eso son 127 viajes por segundo,
lo que demuestra que es un fenómeno transcultural.
Lo fascinante es que tanto conductores como pasajeros
informan que el ver un nombre
y ver la foto de alguien y su puntuación
les hace sentirse más seguros,
e incluso, como pueden haber experimentado,
comportarse de una manera más agradable en el taxi.
Uber y Didi son ejemplos tempranos pero poderosos
de cómo la tecnología está creando confianza entre las personas
de maneras y a una escala que antes habría sido imposible.
Hoy en día, muchos de nosotros estamos cómodos
metiéndonos en coches conducidos por desconocidos.
Quedamos con alguien con quien nos han emparejado
al deslizar el dedo hacia la derecha.
Compartimos nuestros hogares con gente a la que no conocemos.
Esto es solo el comienzo,
porque la verdadera disrupción que está ocurriendo
no es tecnológica.
Se trata del giro en la confianza que produce.
Por mi parte, quiero ayudar a que la gente comprenda
esta nueva era de la confianza
para que podamos hacerlo bien
y podamos aceptar las oportunidades
para rediseñar sistemas
que sean más transparentes, inclusivos y responsables.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)
Gracias.